this meme has confused a lot of people
we each put twenty dollars in the Box I
sell you the box for thirty dollars we
both make ten dollars profit infinite
money problem
let's go through the steps we have the
seller on the left the buyer on the
right and we have the box of money in
the first cell we each put twenty
dollars in the box so each of us are
negative twenty and the box is plus
forty in the next cell I sell you the
box for thirty dollars so the seller
gets plus thirty the buyer is negative
Thirty and nothing happens to the box
but the buyer will take the contents of
the box so the buyer gets plus 40 and
the box is negative forty so what
happens in the end the seller is plus 10
the buyer is negative 10 and the box is
zero we don't make ten dollars profit
each and there is no infinite money and
if you don't believe me I'd be happy to
do this with you as long as I can be the
seller